yeah it's all right though I like it
it's nice put it okay but I am were you
doing going to any it was a how I wanted
your work story what's going on here
Gary here has fixed our lighting problem
or might need a cut off I thought I told
you I was going to fix that you wouldn't
know where to start
I've been really busy at work you know
that what you do Mike I'm a surgeon are
nice well I'll call you when I got
kidney stone and you call me next on the
boat breaks or if the DVD stops working
okay well I'll leave you to it then
well good to meet you Mike again
something's blocking the door honey is
everything all right in there
yes everything's flying go away if
something happened at work yeah
something happened to work something I
did isn't it starting just how we woulda
is and then let's fix it right just [ __ ]
off darling come on Evan you're being
ridiculous you think because of the
electrician why don't you [ __ ] you're
going to change the batteries on your
vibrator while you're at it
you